[Music]
hi I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm an engineer
on the Android developer relations team
hi I'm Chris Broadfoot I work on the
Google Maps Android API team today we're
going to talk to you about the Maps API
for Android and we're going to cover a
few things but to start with us talk
about animation if you have a look at
the the sample code for the Maps API
you'll see that we use handlers to
animate markers and for other purposes
too so what we're going to talk about
today is how you can use handlers for
backward compatibility but use some of
the newer API is ie the property
animation framework to have an even
better experience so let's switch to the
tablet and let's just see a basic marker
animating all we're doing is where we
tap we just generate a polyline from the
source to destination just tell the
marker to move there yep so here you
know we've accomplished what we wanted
to but as I said in Gingerbread what
we'd be a gingerbread and although what
we would do is animate these markers the
markers position using a handler so
let's have a look at some code that
shows us how we do this okay so we'll be
showing you three ways of animating a
marker and each of these methods will
have the same parameters so the marker
itself the final destination lat/long so
that's the it's final point and a
lat/long interpolator which we'll talk
about a little bit later so from
Gingerbread and before we need to do a
little bit of setup to set up our
animation handler so first of all we get
the start position just by calling get
position on the marker and then just
again some of that setup so just the
start time and our animation duration so
here's the meet of the animation so this
runnable gets called every 16
milliseconds while the animation
animation is in progress the T variable
is the portion that we are through the
animation and we're also using an
interpolator
so these are available before Ice Cream
Sandwich and honeycomb as well so this
is great for like a accelerate
decelerate Interpol
or bouncing interpolation and then we
just go ahead and call that set position
on the marker with its new value you'll
see at the end of the handler what we do
is we re invoke the handler after 16
milliseconds and of course that magic
number is used so that we can get 60
frames per second now one of the
downsides to this is that we are doing
this asynchronously to the Android UI
rendering thread so what we can do is
use the property animation framework and
we're going to shift to the next one and
see in the value animator how we can
synchronize those okay so from honeycomb
onwards we can use value animator as
Ankur said so here we still have to do a
little bit of setup we get the markers
starting position but the value animator
can give us the animated fraction so
this is the combination of how far the
animation is through and also the
interpolator so any accelerate
decelerate is applied to that as well
and so we just again call set position
on that so the on animation update
override it gets invoked as the next
frame is being prepared so literally
that's your opportunity to do whatever
changes you want to make and then the
frame will get drawn unlike the handler
which is just going to happen every 16
milliseconds regardless of you know when
you're drawing you your next frame this
happens synchronized with that rendering
framework now the interesting thing is
or important thing is you want to make
sure you complete your execution within
16 milliseconds otherwise you're gonna
miss that drawer and you're gonna get
jank or jitter the actual animation of
the value we're just we're not really
using that as you can see we say ignored
because we're animating from 0 to 1 but
it's we're not actually utilizing that
at all so let's talk about object
animator which is also available from
honeycomb upwards but Ice Cream Sandwich
adds some other nice options I suppose
so here we're using an object animator
and we can just create so if you see
down on this line we just create an
object animator of the marker and it's
property position we pass it in a type
of valuator which basically tells the
animation framework how to animate
between custom object types so in this
case
it's a latitude/longitude object and we
just passed in the final position so
there's no need to call market get
position at the start of the animation
which is quite nice so the type of
valuator is very simple in fact it's
very similar to our lat/long
interpolator object which we'll show you
in the next section so the I mean the
the other advantage that I can see here
is that we've actually got significantly
less code to do this now then when we
started so you can obviously group
properties you can group different
objects in here as well so you can
animate things you know in bundles yeah
this works well with the property's
value holder for example yeah all right
so that's animation now let's switch
back to our tablet Chris why don't you
walk us through the next problem okay so
our animation is very simple we're just
animating the latitude and longitude
values of the lat/long object separately
so this has some problems on the surface
of the earth where things wrap around
the dateline so at the 180th longitude
is actually the same point as minus 180
longitude so you'll notice if we try to
animate the cross the mark is going to
go all the way around the world instead
of taking the shortest path so we can
fix this very simply let's go over to
the code so here's our broken
interpolator
it just takes the Latin long and and
takes a linear interpolation of each
value and our fixed one just figures out
whether we should take a shorter path or
not so it just sees if the distance it
needs to travel is more than 180 degrees
so let's switch back to the tablet and
just see what happens there
so this is the the broken one where
we're traveling around the world to get
to that that shortest distance if we
just switch to our fixed one you'll
notice that we get that path yeah so
it's very simple so you may notice that
the marker doesn't exactly follow this
polyline that we've added to the map so
the polyline that we're using has a
geodesic property which means that it's
taking the shortest path on the surface
of the earth as opposed to a straight
line on the surface of the map
so we can if we wanted our market to
follow the polyline we can use similar
spherical map mathematics to do this
interpolation instead switching back to
the laptop yes so this one's quite a bit
more complex you probably won't be
writing this function yourself instead
you should probably just copy and paste
it or include the Android Maps utils
library but basically it just does this
spherical math so if we switch back to
the tablet here it is broken just to
show you that it's it's actually not
following that line yeah and let's
switch to spherical yeah so let's let's
go near the poles for example where this
is more obvious so yeah so you can see
there's quite a quite a large bow and
the mark is following the line exactly
and if we go back to the broken one
you'll see that it goes straight across
yeah so so the spherical method is very
useful if you want this market to follow
a line like we are here or if your
markers have some sort of actual
geographic importance like perhaps a
plane on the map or something like that
just animating the latitude and
longitude separately is fine for short
distances or if you don't really care
about any geographic properties and it's
probably quite a bit faster than the
spherical methods there's a lot of maths
in there yeah so please do check out the
the code that we have here we'll put an
annotation in into the the video gonna
be on anchors face and we we hope you
found this useful